Speaker 1: Tomorrow on the show, we're going to
spend some time talking about the overt Christian
nationalist movement. And the Republican Party now
is overtly Christian nationalist there. They're
straight up saying we're sick of the separation of
church and state, so if we're sick of all of it.
But I want to give you another data point in
this today before we do our bigger story on it
tomorrow. Marjorie Taylor GREENE, among others,
spoke at the Turning Point USA event over the
weekend. We're going to look at more clips of
this. We'll look at Trump's speech and Don Jr
speech and Lauren Boebert saying i never
was an escort. I never was a prostitute.
For Ted Cruz, really weird, weird event.
But before we get into that in more detail,
there was this one moment where Marjorie
Taylor GREENE said, Christian nationalism
is great. That's what we need. Let's take a
look at this video clip and then we'll discuss.
Speaker 2: Perfect. It just means we're doing
the right thing. And I think that's what the
Republican Party needs to be about. Huh? I'm a
Christian. How many Christians do we have here?
So you see, I also call myself a Christian
nationalist, and that's not a bad word.
Speaker 3: Hmm.
Speaker 2: That's
actually a good thing, right? And there's nothing
wrong with leading with your in with your faith,
because we should lead with our faith. Because
if we're doing that, then we're doing the right
thing. It doesn't mean we're perfect. It
just means we're doing the right thing.
Speaker 1: So she says that that's what the
Republican Party should be about. Now, Christian
nationalism is not just we happen to be Christian
and we like the United States or whatever
Christian nationalism means. You believe United
States as a nation is defined by Christianity.
Government should be actively keeping
the United States a Christian nation.
The United States government should be imposing or
prioritizing or giving preference to Christianity.
There should be Christianity should be
the doctrine, a prescriptive doctrine
for how the government runs. And you're sort of
breaking down separation of church and state.
This is not unique to Marjorie Taylor GREENE
that the belief that Christianity should be
privileged in the public square. Remember, we've
looked at clips of Lauren Boebert. Lauren Boebert
openly is calling for the same thing now.
Speaker 2: And I believe that great patriots
all throughout this nation and Christians
will begin to position themselves
in these days and these times that pastors would
have a pulpit to speak from the pulpit of their
churches to direct and inform the church on
how to influence the direction of government.
Speaker 1: So that's pretty full on. And
if that's not direct enough for you here,
she was saying she's tired of this separation
of church and state stuff. We looked at
this about a month ago when it took place.
Speaker 2: The reason we had so many overreaching
regulations in our nation is
because the church complied.
The church is supposed to direct the government.
The government is not supposed to direct the
church. That is not how our Founding Fathers
intended it. And I'm tired of the separation
of church and state junk that's not in the
Constitution. It was in a stinking letter,
and it means nothing like what they say it does.
Speaker 1: Now, I've told you before that she's
wrong. In fact, when they say it was in a stinkin
letter. What they're trying to do is minimize
the idea, the desire for separation of church and
state to like an offhanded, casual letter written
by Thomas Jefferson. That's what Lauren Boebert
wants you to believe. She wants you to believe
it's all it's all a big mistake. There was no
actual desire for separation of church and state.
Thomas Jefferson sort of mentioned it in one
letter. And that said. But the reality is that
were they deists or not, were they Christians or
not? The founding fathers very clearly recognized
and it's established in the Constitution that
there should be no prioritization of one religion
over another, nor of religion over non religion
in the United States. It's abundantly clear the
fact that we're going back to that. You know, one
of the things Republicans love to do is they don't
just want to go back to the 1950s. They also want
to go back to debates that have been long settled
and that anybody who takes them seriously
realizes there actually is no debate about.
And this is extraordinarily dangerous. So
we're going to talk tomorrow on the on the show
about the decidedly Christian nationalist move
of the Republican Party. Not everybody in the
Republican Party agrees with it. I mean, someone
like Adam Kinzinger, he doesn't agree with it.
He's also retiring and is kind of increasingly
irrelevant within the party. But even Trump now
is regularly at his rallies, and we might look
at the clip later saying we kneel only before God
and all of these different sort of signals to the
Christian nationalist. So this is a very dangerous
movement in particular, because if they do well in
November and then they control the 2024 election,
there are all sorts of ways in which they can
impose this Christianity in the public square
completely antithetical. I mean, without a doubt
completely antithetical to what the framers
wanted. So we will talk about
it more. And in the meantime,
you can send me your thoughts by
finding me on Twitter at David Pakman.